There are treaties in place like the Montreal
Protocol and Paris Agreement to help stem
the rise of global temperatures and greenhouse
gases.
But we might have other tools for managing
climate change at our disposal, one of which,
oddly, comes from Pluto.
In July of 2015, the New Horizons spacecraft
flew by Pluto.
Among the wealth of data the spacecraft gathered
was the dwarf planet’s global temperature.
And it was a strange result.
From ground-based measurements taking into
account Pluto’s atmosphere and how much
that atmospheric composition would reflect
and absorb solar radiation, scientists had
estimated the planet would be on the order
of about 100 degrees Kelvin.
4But the data that came back said otherwise.
Pluto was colder, on average, just 70 K.
A team of researchers suspects that the cause
is not Pluto’s atmosphere but a haze that
surrounds the planet.
Among the gases that make up Pluto’s thin
-- or rare -- atmosphere are nitrogen and
methane.
When UV light from the Sun reaches the atmosphere,
both gases become ionized, kicking off electrons
in the process.
They then react to form complex hydrocarbons
that are heavy enough to fall to the surface.
These are called “tholins” and they give
Pluto it’s reddish hue.
The haze caused by these heavy particles also
cool the planet.
They have higher solar heating and thermal
cooling rates than gas molecules, and because
they dominate the atmosphere their impact
is significant.
What’s really interesting here is the degree
to which these particles cool Pluto.
The temperature difference is more than a
factor of 10 greater than the impact humans
have had on Earth’s atmosphere with things
like emissions and greenhouse gases.
So, what if we took this idea and brought
it home?
What if a similar process on Earth could curb
global temperature rise?
Scientists have actually seen a similar phenomenon
on our own planet…
Called Global Dimming, it’s not caused by
complex hydrocarbons but by a combination
of natural factors like ash from forest fires
and man-made pollutants in the atmosphere.
These particles attract water molecules that
then form clouds that reflect more sunlight
back into space.
Less sunlight hitting the ground means less
heating.
There is, however, a major downside.
More clouds and atmospheric water could affect
global rainfall patterns leading to drought,
which would take a toll plant growth.
And that would have a huge impact on the global
ecosystem.
Throwing particles into the atmosphere might
also conceal the full effect of global warming.
If the dimming happens in conjunction with
the rise in global temperatures, it might
mask the severity of our planet’s sensitivity
to greenhouse gases.
But information is our greatest ally.
If we can understand and control global dimming,
it could be another defense against climate
change.
If you liked this video be sure to subscribe
for more Seeker in your life.
Crazy geoengineering projects like this are
incredible, and this is just one of many.
Julian has a run-down of some more, here.
And on global dimming, the amount of sunlight
reaching the surface today is, on average,
less than it was in the 1950s.